老问我一表，
失恋的这种下该怎么走出来？
首先，
第一，
绝不干伤害自己的事情，
绝不去酒吧买醉，
绝不像电影里面翻茴那样，
失恋吧，
找个不了解的人去睡一觉，
试图让前男友愧疚，
这种做法就是蠢。
第二，
绝不做那种跪着哭着求对方原谅，
求对方回到你身边的事儿，
你越是这样作践自己，
越是这样，
她越挑劲，
她越想逃离你。
第三，
最重要的点就是好好修整自己，
好好的倒饬自己，
去做个头发，
去做个美甲，
去搓个澡，
去美容院，
去护个肤，
怎么都行，
别一天天的以泪洗烟，
一天天的不吃饭不睡觉，
熬的自己跟个老脸膜似的，
熬的自己满脸都是斑，
熬给谁看？
以龙菲姐的经验来看，
让自己变得更好是解决一切问题的关键。
我原来状态也不好，
带孩子熬夜熬的满脸都是斑，
你让我去搞个项目吧，
怕疼，
让我去搞那种特别猛的那些美白的那些东西吧，
怕烂脸，
但是我用那款就是米家他们家的这个美白祛斑的这个籽油，
真管用啊，
人家是美白祛斑的特征的，
既能有。
养肤又能美白祛斑，
皮肤是清油不清水，
有很多姐妹就是皮肤干啊，
老以为说是补水补水不，
其实不是，
就是你那个水油平衡不行了，
你必须要把这个水油平衡给解决掉，
它里面就添加了很多很好的美白成分，
植物377黑白霜，
珍珠，
还有专门针对小黑黑的欧诗草提取物，
6:4的水油配比护肤脸肤感特别好，
这个是精华水包裹的精华油，
用之前一定要摇一摇啊，
涂上脸很快就吸收了。
你看秋冬就特别适合，
淡淡的花香味道也特别治愈，
用了整个过程就特别舒心，
还可以配合一个花花板的用，
这样效果更好。
与其把时间花在那些不爱你的男人身上，
不如好好倒饬自己，
只要你变得越来越好男人。